und da bin ich auf die duelle jetzt
gespannt ja da breche dich jetzt nennen
wir wollen natürlich alle schauen nach
münchen markus söder gibt jetzt also
seine pressekonferenz es wird erwartet
dass er das ergebnis vom cdu
bundesvorstand an den csu-vorsitzenden
ministerpräsident dr markus söder und
von csu-generalsekretär markus blume ja
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die würfel sind gefallen
armin laschet wird kanzlerkandidat der
union ein wort das ich gegeben habe gilt
seit einer woche
wir haben ein angebot gemacht wir werden
bereit gewesen unserem land zu dienen
in der zentralen spitzenfunktionen und
position der deutschen politik und wir
haben für dieses angebot unglaublich
viel zuspruch erhalten
ich bedanke mich da ausdrücklich dafür
bei vielen vielen orts und
kreisverbänden der cdu besonders
ich bedanke mich sehr bei
arbeitsgemeinschaft gerade bei den
jungen bei den modernen bei denen die
auf zukunft aus waren für ihre wirklich
überragende unterstützung
ich bedanke mich vor allem auch bei
vielen mutigen abgeordneten die entgegen
normale partei ist solidarität sehr
offen gesagt haben was sie schätzen
ich bedanke mich auch bei nahezu allen
ministerien die gerade den letzten tagen
auch noch mal unterstützung gezeigt
haben und ganz besonders bei unglaublich
vielen bürgern und bürgern unseres
landes nicht nur aus bayern
wir haben überall aus deutschland
zuspruch erhalten und selten so viel wie
ein csu oder bayern es eigentlich hier
bekommen hat und es hat mich gefreut
es hat mich bewegt und ich gebe zu
etliches auch gerührt
das hätte ich nicht gedacht deswegen war
die bereitschaft sich zu erklären
wichtig für mich ist aber klar es gibt
verantwortung für das land das wäre die
bereitschaft gewesen zu kandidieren
aber es gibt auch verantwortung für die
union nur eine geschlossene union kann
am ende erfolgreich sein
in unserer demokratie die wir leben die
nicht nur eine demokratie ist nach
ritualen des gestern die modernität auch
erfordert ist es wichtig dass parteien
nicht nur diskutieren sondern sie am
ende auch zusammenfinden
wir wollen keine spaltung wir wollen
eine geschlossene gemeinschaft
sie haben wir das immer gesagt es gibt
kein kreuz 1976 und es gibt auch keinen
sommer 20 18
natürlich gibt es unterschiedliche
ambitionen und personen
aber für mich ist und war wichtig dass
wir als neue csu in diesen schwierigen
zeiten anstand und stil zu einem
grundprinzip dass die gemeinsamkeit
setzen
ich habe gestern gesagt und einige von
ihnen haben mich gefragt gilt es dann
auch genau diese frage
die cdu muss entscheiden und wenn sie
entscheidet halten wir uns daran das
habe ich gesagt und das gilt auch die
cdu hat gestern abend getagt und
entschieden und wir akzeptieren das und
ich respektiere ist ich habe ihn
angerufen und habe ihm gratuliert habe
ihm auch gesagt dass wir jetzt als csu
akzeptieren wir haben auch die volle
unterstützung angeboten als csu in
diesen wie ich glaube außerordentlich
schwierig im wahlkampf den es geben wird
und wir werden ihn ohne groll mit voller
kraft unterstützen das kann ich für mich
ganz persönlich aber ich glaube auch für
uns der csu sagen das werden wir tun
jetzt kommt es darauf an
zusammenzustehen und zusammen zu rücken
es wird sicher noch diskussionen geben
aber wir jedenfalls werden unseren
beitrag zum gemeinsamen erfolg leisten
es gibt tage der diskussion es gibt tage
der entscheidung
das ist jetzt passiert und danach ist es
wichtig gemeinsam in die zukunft zu
schauen
deswegen wünsche ich auch im namen der
csu ganz persönlich armin laschet für
die schwierige aufgabe die vor ihm steht
viel erfolg und bietet wie gesagt noch
einmal die unterstützung der csu
herzlichen dank